three two one here we go
hey what's up my name is welcome to
another winners on a wednesday
every single week i interview one of my
success students
welcome to joshua joshua is on the
academy and he's been in where did you
join the academy joshua
february last year so pretty much a year
i think it was 10 days ago it's been a
year
nice so you had your anniversary exactly
yeah
incredible so when we first met you
at the property investors crash course
you've just done a property flip so
you're not new to the industry
yeah um what were you doing what have
you previously done
how old were you when we first met so
crash course i'll have been 22. yeah i
can remember it was it was at the uh
somewhere in london at one of the hotels
um yeah i was
22 i was saying i was kitchen bathroom
fitting so
full-time job nine to five uh she had
just come off the back of a flip i don't
know my parents i was you know very
fortunate to be able to kind of do that
with them
yeah and that really got me looking at a
property so yeah i was saying 905 i was
just looking for that
you know almost to get out from the nine
of five just i wanted to do something
with
my own life and be able to kind of you
know dictate my own future kind of thing
exactly the flip that you did with you
folks what was what was the structure of
that
so it was pretty much just i guess it
was a give like they pretty much put the
money in
um as i said between me and my dad we
pretty much did all the work so there
was not really anyone else involved
um we pretty much just bought it i i
bought the property in my name
they put the money in to do the refurb
yeah and between us we just did the work
and and sold it strong
nice and you made how much do you make
on that i think there's about twenty
thousand a piece
okay yeah it was pretty good you mean
you mean each yeah
right so when you made you 20 grand see
a lot of people
they're in they're in the industry
they're in the um you know trades person
you've just done a flip where you've
done the refurb yourself would think i
don't really need to do the academy i
don't need to really get through what
what made you
uh well firstly what was the crash
course like and what made you come to
the decision that you wanted to invest
a big sum of money right 12 000 pounds
yeah
into the academy like what made you do
that and what happened at the crash
course
yeah i think the thing at the crash
course i mean in my opinion
i had two choices i could either join
the academy
or invest in a buy to let the buyer to
let i mean
the area i'm from i didn't really know
anything about property at a time apart
from battlelets and flips
so in my opinion i'd if i would have
invested that money and probably made
100
a month yeah on top of you know getting
a rental
um so it was either that or the academy
and i thought you know what
the academy i'd be investing a big chunk
of that money yes
but i'd also have the skills to be able
to do gabs work with other people
sell deals to other people so
you know even though i'd be making that
investment and taking a big lump out of
the money i had
i'd have the skills and the knowledge
moving forward to almost
not need that money yeah if that makes
sense um so yeah the crash course i mean
it was a it really was an eye-opener for
me i went into that i was skeptical i'll
be honest
um i went into the crash course i think
was the first day i've signed
i've signed up for the academy so it was
just a pure
energy and i think the networking as
well was a big one for me because i've
never really
been in a room full of such incredible
people
yeah and i thought you know what this is
the environment that i need to be in to
grow
and kind of get out of my comfort zone
yeah because you were uncomfortable with
that
are you 100 100 speaking i
going at the crash course i was so so
nervous i mean
it was probably the biggest thing i'd
ever done yeah um
you know i went on my own just travel
for london on my own
walked into this room full of probably
300 400 people and just thought
i don't know i don't know what to do i
don't know who to speak to where to go
who to sit with so
it was just so nerve-wracking for me i
mean i
i was a really nervous person i didn't
like speaking to new people
and it was such a big out you know it
was out of my comfort zone it really was
yeah um but yeah coming through the
academy it's just
it's it's forced me out my comfort zone
which is what i needed
um and yeah i mean it's just forced me
to grow i guess it's put me in the
environment where
i don't have a choice yeah and also
positive peer pressure
yeah being around other people that are
doing deals and winning
i mean but and i say this i mean at the
crash course i tell people
you've got to get comfortable being
uncomfortable because if you're not
stepping outside of your comfort zone
you're actually
you're actually dying because you're not
growing so you know massive respect
for doing that thank you hopefully when
you actually got to the crash course
it wasn't as bad as you thought no no
definitely i mean
i did feel welcome straight away i
wasn't you know it's not easy for me to
feel
comfortable um and i definitely wasn't
comfortable for the
the duration of the crash course but i
felt i felt great i could just sit and
meet
new people and yeah it was almost a good
thing that i went on my own because like
i said it forced me to do it
which i needed um but yeah coming off
the back of that again
forcing myself on my comfort zone i set
up a youtube channel which
massively on my comfort zone again i
didn't wanna you know i don't like
speaking on camera i don't
like hearing myself back but i kind of
forced myself to do it and i'm fine with
it
yeah that's awesome man yeah and great
to see i mean we're obviously going to
talk about the properties that you've
done
yeah and and how how you've made the
success of that but also it's
been great to see to the person how
you've grown and developed
um i know you've been going on the the
monthly
coaching accountability calls uh you've
gone through all the different training
programs we've now got everything online
as well
yeah which is awesome um so what deals
have you done what's been your strategy
so my strategy coming out the gear i
pretty much came out the academy
and went a bit crazy so i came out the
academy i i
pretty much back to back to all the
events so
from february to march i've pretty much
completed
you know most of the strategies you're
like full-time student yeah exactly i've
gone into a property full time i quit my
job to do it and just kind of went into
the academy
did as much strain as possible came out
the last event which was rent to rent
and just went a bit nuts i was like i'm
gonna go in this area i'm gonna do this
strategy this that this that
yeah and almost couldn't pinpoint what i
wanted to do i just
spread myself so thinly right that i
couldn't figure out
you know what worked yeah um so
that kind of took me probably three or
four months of just going a bit nuts
um then settled on brr just purely
because i've got a trade background
kitchen bathroom fit and i just thought
you know what
brr i've done a flip perfect for me and
by the way if anyone doesn't know what
brr
is buy refurbished should be financial
resources when you buy a house add value
and then pull the money back out
exactly and you're based in
middlesbrough yeah which isn't a bad
area
no definitely not it's got a lot of
houses that need a refurbishment and me
with a trade background yeah
refurbishment that's perfect yeah um so
yeah when
i went down that route i thought you
know what that's where i'm gonna go
that's the route i'm gonna go down uh
but yeah for whatever reason i just
couldn't seem to pick deals up i
couldn't seem to get them fast enough
um wasn't for lack of drive i just for
whatever reason didn't work out for me
um and got to probably about last august
and
decided you know i have some money there
i just thought you know what i need to
invest this money
and make it work for me so i thought you
know what i'll go to a deal saucer
and take on my rent to rent which i did
um
and off the back of that it kind of got
me an insight into rent to rent and i
just thought you know what this is a
really good strategy
um not only for me but for my investors
as well because i have been working with
investors
um and just thought you know what this
is what i want to do so from there
i just totally pivoted i i didn't really
look back on brr just totally switched
direction and thought rent to rent
that's what i'm gonna do
and just totally committed to rent to
rent yeah and it's interesting as well
because
i would usually recommend i'm quite
against paying your deals also for a
rent to rent yeah
you probably know that you've probably
heard me say yeah with it and the reason
i'm against it though
i guess there's a couple reasons number
one is i think sometimes people think
that having got the education haven't
got the training haven't got the net
worth
they think oh i'm just going to just pay
a deal saucer and then it will all just
magically happen and i'll get the money
whereas renter
is a business yeah so if you are going
to pay i don't think there's anything
wrong with paying a deal so to get rid
of it
the person that you bought the deal off
was on the academy as well
it was safe and you were in the right
environment also you went in with your
eyes wide open knowing exactly what
rental rents are
in the academy but it is a business oh
definitely
it's not a passive income vehicle where
you just paid two grand and you're just
going to be way
financially free it's a business
opportunity yeah and i think that
you know you went in with the right
training with the right support with
your eyes wide open and were able to
come in
knowing how to run that business yeah it
worked for you
and and and we'll talk about what you've
done on citizen because you've got
a lot more but you know i just wanted to
put that out there um i mean i don't
know what you
what what your thoughts are on that as
someone that's done it what do you think
about what i'm saying
yeah i totally agree i mean i went into
that situation i'd
done the training on rent to rent i knew
you know what needed to be done i knew
that it wasn't going to be
me just sitting back paying someone some
money and coming back in my bank account
you know it's a hands-on investment
strategy it's not something that is
passive
however as you say the person i took the
deal from
they are in the academy they're very
reputable and they work with a
management company as well that i now
use
um and that allowed me to make it
passive i mean
i took the deal on i still to this day i
haven't been to the apartment i've never
seen it
wow that's kind of the level of trust i
had in them
and you know it returns me money every
month i get my investment back
um and it's just you know i've never
been it's just purely off numbers
if you haven't got that level of trust
with the deal and the person you're
working with
i wouldn't recommend doing it yeah yeah
i agree if you haven't got that trust if
you haven't got that knowledge the
experience to understand what what what
it is
you know but you've done great with that
and you know you've been making money on
it how much how much was that is that
first renter
making that one has been about 600 a
month profit incredible how much money
did you need to put down to secure it
i think that one it needed a bit of
furniture so i think it was about
five thousand six thousand down great
okay yeah so you'll make that back after
the first year
yeah and then it's profit however since
then you've gone out
you've hustled and you've exactly got
your yeah so tell me about the um
tell me about the deals that you've done
the regiments yeah so the other one
the first one off the deal sorcerer is
in bristol so i decided for the next one
i just thought you know what everything
that i've got is in bristol
as in management company the teams i've
got so i'll stick with bristol
um and just literally through open rent
just
firing messages out left right and
center yeah i was getting calls coming
back to me
and got speaking of one landlord who had
you know the perfect department had just
been refurbished so it was in great
condition
um this was in december i took it over
last year
um and yeah it was just kind of that was
my next step up
and took my own on and it was direct to
landlord as well which was even better
um and yeah that one's on for three
years so that's kind of that was my
second one and then juice this morning
literally on the way up here
i've got contracts signed for five
bedding cardiff as well incredible
that's gonna be really really good
that's great so how are you getting
these rental events because this is one
of the questions i get asked
all the time people say people say i'm
getting told no i can't make the deal
stack
um i can't find landlords
no one wants to do corporate let's how
are you finding these deals
what are you doing what are you saying
yeah i mean
i get the same questions i mean me
personally i don't
try and oversell it i pretty much if i'm
going on open rent
i'll literally send a message to any
landlord and open rent that their
property might look suitable to me so
open rent is
like the uh right move equivalent but
direct to landlords
lettings only yeah you're on open rent
yeah
you're messaging the landlords what do
you say you just request a book of
viewing
no so i i do introduce it i say look
would this literally a short message
i hope you well would this apartment be
you know available on a corporate
for three to five years that's it that's
right short
sweet simple yeah initial message yeah
no we don't do corporate let's yeah some
people go oh let's have a conversation
exactly to be honest a lot of people
don't know what it is and it's the three
to five years it kind of pricks three is
up
yeah and then i just say if it is please
give me a call
if they are interested in three to five
years they'll give me a call and then
i'm on the phone with them rather than
messaging through open ram which is
again it's a lot better yeah um and yeah
i just have a conversation with them i'm
just open and honest and say look this
is what it is
the fact that i had one previously and
it was in bristol that really stood me
in good stead to be honest i think
if i if i didn't have one already it
probably would have been tougher
but when you've already got one there
and you can say look this is what i've
got this is how it runs you can see
pictures of it
that really kind of makes them a bit
more open to it and
trusts you a little bit more yeah so
yeah that's that's pretty much all i say
i'll just
basically tell them exactly what it is
tell them you know the management
company that i use they've got
quite a lot of properties i think
they're up to about 200 now so
they are big and that number kind of
gives
that you know it gives me credibility by
saying the management company are good
so yeah i pretty much just tell them
exactly what it is how i work
um and yeah did you suffer a lot of
rejection or was it reasonably quite
straightforward
yeah but i think i said probably to get
this one i probably sent about
150 200 messages a lot of messages yeah
i mean it takes
i'll probably send 30 a day so it
doesn't take that long to kind of rack
up a lot of messages
um and from the back of that you
probably get probably 20 30 calls
yeah so you do go through quite a lot of
calls but
it doesn't take that much time if it's
interesting as well joshua because
depending on how you look at it if when
you send a message to a landlord you
make it into a big deal like i'm gonna
write the message okay send
oh and then you wait and you're looking
and then they a message back oh and then
you're gonna call
and oh they reject you oh no i need to
spend a few hours out but
if you think of it like that which most
people do yeah
then it's like it speaks to 20 people
it's horrible
yeah but if in your mindset it's like
actually you know what if i was an
estate agent getting paid a
grand a month which by the way a lot of
state agencies have paid yeah that's
about a month
right i would have to literally spend
9 00 a.m until 6 00 p.m on the phone on
the phone
constantly that'll be my job right so if
you treat your
business even just like how most people
have paid a grand a month
treat their job which is just to make
when i was on stage and i had to make 40
calls a day yeah right
so you do that on your business you're
gonna get a deal
in like a few days yeah of course i mean
i it probably took me maybe half an hour
on a morning to send 30 messages
literally a copy and paste job and put
in the name it was nothing nothing
complicated it was just a straight copy
and paste job yeah
and that was it half an hour on the
morning straight away as i wake up and
it's done
yeah and then from that i think the the
thing like
people do stress over it and people
think you know what i'm going to say
again it forces you out your comfort
zone once you've sent that message
they're then ringing you and you haven't
got a choice whether you want to speak
to them or not because they're on the
phone
yeah so you haven't got a choice right
that's one of the on the way we do uh
uh our trainings which you've been
through which is great but but like we
get you to do stuff right so
send the message now go and then you'll
send the message uh-oh
now they're gonna call me right now let
me teach you about what to say and it's
like
you know the way that we teach is very
much theory and practice together yeah
going you know going hand in hand what
was your experience going through the
academy training programs like what was
it like
yeah i should say it's not you know i
wasn't
you know i didn't have any expectations
going into it but i didn't think it was
going to be
as hands-on as it is it's pretty much
you learn a little bit and then you go
and do it you learn a bit more and then
you go and do it it's not
sit down look at a whiteboard all day
and read slides it's it's
really hands-on and really kind of you
know there's people there actually
helping you through
it it's not just that's you know what
you're gonna learn now off you go and
try it yeah yeah it really is you know
we'll teach you
and then we'll sit down and do it with
you and even after you finish the
training like
you've done all the training you went
off but we've still got all the
accountability
cards the mentoring the support and
everything like that i think sometimes
people forget as well
that when you enroll into the academy
you're not just
paying for the information you're
investing in yourself you're investing
into your network you're investing into
the support you're gonna get as you go
through it
which has paid off for you yeah um so
now you've got
how many rental events have you got
right now then right now there's two
that are alive both in bristol and then
one that's
going to be set up probably within the
next week and yeah just securing cardiff
exactly and then you've got more
leads and stuff yeah well strangely the
the one in cardiff i actually found
basically the story was i went to view a
property in cardiff that was a fire bed
and it didn't pay off however about a
week later
this random person gave me a call and
said oh you went to view my friend's
property in cardiff
it didn't pay off but i've got my
property that i'd like to do you know
the same thing on
i had messaged him at all it was just
purely from me you know speaking to
someone else
he then rings me and now it's turned
into a rent to rent for me
great i didn't go out and do anything
for that but he
came to me so i guess it's the more
you're putting out there yeah the more
comes back and now this same guy
turns out he's a builder and has a lot
of properties so he's now passed on
another two
that are already set up that his wife
was doing um
but just doesn't want to manage anymore
she's having a baby so he's now passing
them to me which potentially is two more
ladies
so it's strange how things come about
but yeah you've just got to put yourself
out there and things do come back
absolutely absolutely and you've also i
know you've got your enter rents which
is great and it's making
because as well you can have five or ten
rental rents but if they're only making
200 a month it's not really worth that
yeah it's not worth the hassle you've
got a smaller amount but they're making
quite a decent amount of profit
yeah how much are you gonna be making
off this card if uh
cardiff one i mean it's very very little
in because it was set up as a hmo and
has
got furniture already but i think it's
going to be around you know between 500
and a thousand a month depending on
occupancy
um but yeah i'd say it was very little
money how much money did you have to put
in
it was about 4 000 for a five-bed
property which
you know furniture-wise isn't huge yeah
um so yeah it was
relatively small what's the breakdown of
that four thousand break it down i think
there's about
three thousand well probably about two
thousand seven hundred was furniture so
you know putting the bits and bobs in
for an seo rather than a hmo
yeah and then i also pay set up costs
because again i've never even viewed
that one it's
purely down to the management company
because i'm in middlesbrough and that's
in card if it's miles for me to travel
so i pretty much just ring the
management company
they go and view it for me they'll
charge you like 30 quid to go and view
it
they know whether it's going to work for
them because they're going to be
managing it
if it works they'll tell me they'll send
me a video and everything like that if i
want to go ahead with it they'll go and
pick the keys up furnish it make it live
and do everything
what are the risks of doing rent to rent
because
there is risk involved especially if
you're not going to be viewing it and
it's like very very hands-off
i mean one of the things that we teach
on the academy and you've probably heard
me say a million times is
you gotta look at what the best case is
you've also gotta look at what the worst
case is
yeah um and of course you know when we
do rent events our way
we put brake clauses in yeah so that if
after a few months it's not really
working out we can walk away which means
the worst case you've only lost
maybe a few thousand or whatever you've
put down um
best case could be a grand a month yeah
five years
amazing and then you make make the
decision but what would you say some of
the
pitfalls or the things that people need
to be careful of people need to look out
for
when they're getting a regular deal
would be yeah i mean things you've got
to be careful of
i think it's very down to your guests i
mean
if you get a bar to let you get one
tenant in there they could stay there
for years whereas rent to rent
you could have a different guest in
there every three days two days
something like that
yeah and that is very you know you've
got to have somebody there every time
to clean it and make sure it's really
good condition
otherwise you're going to have bad
reviews and if you get bad reviews
that's kind of a bit of a you know
downward spiral
yeah so you have got to have a really
good operation there and
you know trust your operation if you
haven't got a management company there
and
you know people there getting guests in
and also making sure that the guests
have a good time and it's clean and
everything like that
you're gonna struggle so i think
you know off the bat you've got to have
either you're going to manage it
yourself and you've got to do a really
good job or you've got to have someone
there that
you can trust to manage it yeah but i'll
say pitfalls i mean
i do put bert claus in my agreement so
you've got to kind of will
if if nothing works and you don't work
any money
that's kind of the worst case you're
going to be paying rent for
you know three four five six months
whatever breakfast you have
um but yeah best case you know you're
going to earn a lot of money off it
what would you say due diligence and
checks you need to do on an area
before deciding on whether to take on a
rent to rent
so the checks i do personally i mean
i've got a really good relationship with
the management company and they work
heavily in the areas that i've invested
in yeah so they're
really knowledgeable so i can kind of
see what they've done already and what
their occupancy rates are
but i also look at everyone else's so
you know i'll go on a dnl
kind of you know unlock the uh the
premium thing for the area if you like i
don't just you know look at the
the cheap way of doing it so yeah they
might cost me 16 pounds a month to
unlock the area which
it's definitely worth it so i can kind
of see what everyone else's occupancy
rates are what they're charging and
everything like that so
you've just got to do as much as you can
just for anyone doesn't know what is air
dna and
how does that work dna it's pretty much
a platform that i think it only analyzes
airbnb and one of the site i can't
remember
my head but yeah pretty much airbnb
that's what it analyzes
it doesn't do booking.com or anything
like that or direct bookings but
you can get a really good idea of you
know what the occupancy rates are in the
area what people are charging
so it's just worth looking at and it
also splits up
you can see what the you know the top
fifty percent the top twenty five
percent in the top
uh ten percent of units are doing in the
area so yeah
if you know that you're going to be
performing within the top 10 in the area
and doing really good
you know what you're going to be you
know occupancy and charging as well yeah
it's really important do you do
diligence check out market research on
the area yeah
have if you're not going to go to the
property and if it is going to be hands
off
make sure you've got a really good team
that you can trust in the area yeah
which again is all part of networking
and
and who you know what you know you've
also you've not just done registration
you did you flip before the academy
you've done rent to rent which is great
which is making you a decent income now
yeah 100
i mean what kind of income are you
making with yourself your uh
in total off of your entrance now so
right now the ones i've got probably
about 1200 a month which
is what my income was before i started
the academy so
wow equaled that and then again i've got
the five bed so that
that one is going to be earning you know
good money compared to the owns the five
bed it's gonna push it to closer to two
thousand
definitely yeah which is which is well
as you say you were on 1200 before so
that's incredible that's like basic
financial freedom now exactly
yeah which is incredible but you're also
doing sourcing yeah you've got a couple
of bespoke
sorting clients you've recently signed
up tell me about that yeah so
i was trying to when i was trying to
sauce before i saw some brrs it was
pretty much me saying
this is what i could do whereas when
you've kind of put yourself in those
shoes and you're thinking you know
i've done the rent to rent already it's
this is what i've done
right rather than this is what i could
do for someone else and it's a very
different
conversation i have because people can
see what you've done already and they
can see
what they're gonna get yeah it's like
you you know if you said someone this is
what you could have rather than
look what i've got do you want the same
it's a it's a totally different
conversation i have
yeah so by me investing even in just one
unit and putting you know
it's not a huge investment to put in you
know considering you could get
you know the sports arts agreements and
that sort of thing off the back of it
it's worth doing purely because
people are looking at what i'm doing and
without me even having that conversation
with them of
do you want to invest with me they're
coming to me
and saying you know i want to invest i
want to invest i've got people coming
now that are saying you know
i want to invest i want to put my money
in with you
and i haven't even gone and spoken to
them just because they're seeing what
i'm doing yeah
which you know it's great i i've wanted
that since day one and now it's finally
coming back which is
amazing because success breeds success
yeah your first deal's always your
hardest deal
you know you registered for the academy
and i mean normally when you go to
university that's like the university is
a two-year course yeah
you think when i finish una i want to
then go and get a job or i want to
whereas with the academy what you do and
what most people do is they say
what i'm on the academy i want to get
some results exactly now it's been 12
months
and the accountability program of course
we're still connecting to the ground
but but now it's like you you've got to
this point but i've i thought with your
journey as well
like you're just getting started oh yeah
100 i mean i
i personally i mean yes i've kind of
replaced my old income and that sort of
thing but
in my opinion i haven't even got started
like the things that i want to do i want
to set up
a management company to manage
everything myself i want to you know
grow
my portfolio and other people's
portfolios as well so
me personally i feel like i've i've
barely even touched this are you 23 the
same kind of age as most people when
they finish university
it's almost like instead of you
finishing uni and then going looking for
a job you've just finished the academy
you're now making between 1200 it will
be about 2
000 which has replaced your income yeah
but now you've got this massive career
ahead of you
oh yeah to build a property empire yeah
um you know which is absolutely
incredible
yeah you've also um i mean i think from
what i can see on socials and stuff it
looks like you've made quite a lot of
friends as well
oh 100 i mean that to me is the the
biggest
most important thing that i've found
coming through the academy is just pure
network
yeah i think you know it's all good and
well coming out the academy and having
all you know the different skills and
and strategies and everything that's
great but if you haven't got a network
where
you know you can rely on people to help
you then
you know you're always going to struggle
right i did the same thing came out the
academy
i've kept in touch with people but not
that regularly yeah
and it is a lonely road i mean you'll
know yourself when you're trying to do
that sort of thing
and there isn't many other people that
do that it's quite lonely but when
you're
you know you're getting in touch with
people i mean i'm in a what's up group
with
a lot of academy members and everyone's
doing really well
and we have calls every saturday night
and just kind of catch up and
and help each other and that on its own
i mean that's just amazing yeah you've
got the accountability there
and also people you know giving your
ideas tips that can help you along i
mean
the people in there there's there's
people in there that are behind me
there's people in there that are way way
further on than me
so you've kind of got a mix of you know
everyone yeah so i think just
network is kind of the biggest thing i
mean like say the management company
that i've got
purely that you know that is some of my
network and i can trust them to go and
view properties for me set them up you
know
live and you know if i didn't have that
network of people
i'd be running around doing viewings and
trying to yeah yeah myself which
i couldn't do i know and most people as
well that try and like tap into a
network or whatever
they type into a network of other
wannabe investors
and everyone's talking about it and it
was oh
whereas i think they think what you've
done is you've got a group of people
around you they're actually doing it
yeah you know maybe not necessarily all
you know millionaires whatever no
they're all in property they're all
doing deals you're more successful than
others
and i think when you're in that
environment you know as i always say
environment is
stronger than willpower it really is um
what would you say to me the biggest
lessons
that you've learned over the last 12
months to do this i mean the biggest
thing for me
is just you know you've got to force
yourself out your comfort zone it
doesn't matter
what your weak points are you've really
got to you know push yourself to work on
them i mean as i said
i was really really you know i wasn't a
people person
but property is a people game you know
you've got to be able to talk to people
and
you know speak to people on the phone
and that sort of thing so for me that
was a big learning curve
um so yeah push yourself out your
comfort zone and
i think sales as well as a big one i
mean i personally i don't have a salesy
background i've never had a sales job
but you know i learned quickly that
you've got to be able to sell whether
you know even if you're trying to put an
offering on a property and you're trying
to buy something
you've got to sell yourself and you're
going to try and sell you know to the
agent for you to get the
property so yeah just i spent a lot of
time learning
you know reading books on sales and
trying to learn how to sell properly
yeah and and that has paid dividends i
mean even speaking to agents you know i
can
put myself across in a manner which you
know
they trust me and the trust you know the
idea that i'm putting across rather than
just
you know ringing and kind of bumbling
along on the phone and yeah and then not
having trust in me because that's when
you're getting the rejections and
getting the doors
yeah so so right and i think when i do
the financial freedom challenges
the thing that really gets me the deals
is the ability to be able to sell
and communicate and as you say sell
yourself yeah i think it's a
people don't like sales in britain
people think oh and i like being sold to
or
yeah but if you don't like being sold to
then you probably don't like selling and
if you don't have selling then you're
going to be broke
because as you say every i think
everything is sales
it is i just tell you to come on this
interview you know
you didn't want to come on particularly
a bit nervous oh my goodness i was like
dude it's going to be fine you know so
everything yourself my kids try and sell
me all the time on staying up a bit
longer we're not going to bed
you know so and you can't and money
doesn't come from property it comes from
people it comes from the tenants it
comes from the investors it comes from
the developers it comes from the
the buyers so you know i think that's a
really really good point
what would you say to someone that was
thinking about going down to a crash
course they will like you a bit
nervous even if it's a virtual one on
zoom if they're just a bit like ooh bit
nervous what would your advice be
just you know you've got to take off you
can't
you know you can't get anywhere by not
taking the first step you've got to do
the first thing even if it's just
booking it like
you know don't think about actually
going on is just make the step to
actually book it
yeah once you've booked it then you can
think about how you're going to get
there yeah well that sort of thing but
yeah
you've just got to do that first thing
it's like me personally i used to be
really nervous to bring agents but
you've just got to dial the number and
click ring and then yes
you've done it then don't think about
the conversation just bring the number
absolutely don't worry about the xyz
yeah what about the abc
sometimes the abc's just getting on your
phone making a call
yeah booking a ticket to a crash course
and then and then worry about
or posting a letter and putting your
number on and then thinking they're
gonna phone now
now if you think about what i'm gonna
say when they phone me hey guys
what an absolutely incredible interview
of joshua i hope you enjoyed that i hope
you're inspired as he said persistence
skills to be able to communicate and get
a deal knowledge
network these are all things that you
need to grow
a property business and to become
financially free so if you want to see
more
interviews you can check out a whole
playlist of over 100
interviews like this i've done with my
success students you can check that out
right here
uh also please don't forget to subscribe
to the channel you can do that right
here
and i look forward to seeing you next
time if you want to book onto the crash
course i'll leave a link in the
description
it's free get booked on see you there
[Music]
you